Many of you have asked us to make a video
about the Mexican elections: arguably, the
most important in
the history of Mexico, which, at the same
time it is the World’s biggest Spanish-Speaking
country.
But
why are these so important?
Because this might be the first in history
where Mexico will say Goodbye to
bipartisan politics.
Election polls: LOPEZ OBRADOR is 10.9 points
above its biggest rival
But wait a minute because, in fact, Mexico
was not an actual bipartisan country.
In fact, Mexico had the
same political party in the government for
over 70 years.
Yes, you heard that right.
Since 1930 until the
year 2000, all the Mexican presidents belonged to the Institutional Revolutionary Party,
also known as
PRI for their Spanish acronym.
And yes, I know what you are thinking…
How can you be Revolutionary and
Institutional at the same time?
Well… nobody knows that.
But this is the name they gave to this party.
Theoretically, this is a center-left wing
party although many Mexicans would say they
are just a catch up
all party, with no clear ideology except by
their lust for power.
The truth is, for 70 years, PRI was winning
every election.
After the year 2000, Mexicans had a 12 years
hiatus of the conservative National Action
Party, also known as PAN.
Then, in 2012, the PRI stroke back
with ENRIQUE PEÑA NIETO as the president,
a guy who now holds the title of Mexico’s
most hated president
of all times.
And this is why in this very moment, 2018,
when Mexico will have this game changing elections
on June the
first, chances are nor the PRI, nor the PAN
will get the office.
The front runner is this man you see on
the screen.
His name is ANDRES MANUEL LOPEZ OBRADOR.
Businessmen are worried by the LOPEZ OBRADOR
economic agenda
This is the third time he runs for office.
And it might the ultimate one.
ANDRES MANUEL LOPEZ OBRADOR,
or, as Mexicans know him, AMLO, has a program
that… to put it mildly, scares the shit
out of business
people and foreign investors.
Some people argue that Mexico might be on
the brink of becoming the new Venezuela if
they choose a
populist politician like him.
Nonetheless, his worst enemy is not businessmen
but himself.
His testimonials are scaring away all the
moderate voters.
And that is a problem because, they could
direct all this anti AMLO sentiment to one
of
the other candidates.
This is why, Today’s questions are: Why
can AMLO win this election?
Are there real
reasons to be scared of him?
And could any other candidate really shadow
him?
Today, we are going to
answer all of this questions but before, let’s
take a look back at history.
THE
BIG MEXICAN DISSAPOINTMENT
At the beginning of the 21st Century, it seemed
that Mexico was taking no prisoners.
With plenty of
natural resources like oil and silver, Mexican
was one of the most appreciated emerging economies.
In
2010, the country’s GDP grew at a 5.5% growing
rate.
Nonetheless, just like the other emerging
economies
like Brazil or South Africa…
Mexico went from hero to zero in 2016.
Mexican GDP in dollars is on it’s worst
level since 2010
This is surprising if we take to account that
Mexico has all the opportunities to become
rich.
They have
oil, good climate for agriculture and all
kinds of natural resources.
And what it’s more important: they
border with America.
As you know, NAFTA is a trade agreement between
Mexico, USA and Canada.
And 80% of
Mexican exports go to Uncle Sam.
Despite all of this, Mexico is still a medium
income country, with low wages and a much
more lower life
quality than its Northern Neighbours.
And do you wonder why?
Well… after 70 years of a, virtually, one
party system, corruption and drug trafficking,
Mexico had almost medieval institutions.
Oh yes, I know what you are gonna say now
‘Come on, Simon, aren’t you exhagerating
a big?’
Well, judge by
yourself.
‘Til the year 2016, their judicial system
had no presumption of innocence so it was
enough to
have a judge collecting proofs to find somebody
guilty.
In many cases, a confession taken with torture
would be more than enough to send somebody
to jail.
Imagine how would this be, that the academia
experts
called this system the ‘inquisitorial judicial
system’.
Add to this the drug trafficking, that has
already killed more than 200 000 people…
in just 11 years!
For
a better understanding, in some areas of Mexico,
narcos have more power than the state itself.
In
political science, this is called a ‘failed
estate’ situation.
And this happens in many areas of Africa…
and in Mexico.
In other words…
Mexico needed more than reforms.
They needed a 1803 shift on their institutions.
And who
was the man for this job?
Of course, that would be ENRIQUE PEÑA NIETO,
when he got to office in 2012.
The
problem?
It is still to early for Mexicans to notice
some improvements on their day to day life
after the
reforms.
In fact, social unrest can’t stop growing.
Add to the fact that PEÑA NIETO’s worst
enemy is PEÑA NIETO himself.
Few people have worked harder in
damaging their own credibility.
Basically, PEÑA NIETO has all the things
needed to hate a politician:
corruption scandals, a fake PHD title and
embezzlement.
But this was not enough!
Do you remember Donald
Trump’s campaign?
He was Messing with Mexicans every other day.
As you can imagine, Mexicans are no big
fans of Trump.
So well…
PEÑA NIETO’s brillian idea was to invite
Trump for an official visit even before
he would become the president.
Guess what was the reaction of the Mexican
people!
And how about the war
on drugs?
First he jailed EL CHAPO GUZMAN, who is the
Mexican version of PABLO ESCOBAR.
After that, EL
CHAPO escaped from jail from a tunnel that
was so good built that it was obvious he got
help from the
police.
In summary… unsurprisingly, PEÑA NIETO
is the man you love to hate.
A Survey in Mexico: PEÑA NIETO is the Mexican
president with the worst acceptance of all
times.
In other words, PEÑA NIETO and his Administration
epitomizes the ultimate disappointment with
Mexican
ruling class.
So PRI is not to be trusted, PAN is not very
exciting either… traditional candidates
are
not a real option anymore.
So what is left?
Well, this is the time… for AMLO!
WHO IS AMLO?
There was a time where AMLO was a member of
the PRI party.
That was in the 70s.
But… look, this
Institutional Revolutionary Party was already
more Institutional than Revolutionary.
This is why AMLO
left them and created another party of his
own: the Democratic Revolutionary Party, the
stronghold of the
true Mexican left.
But… as you can imagine, defeating PRI was
mission impossible… until the year 2000.
That year was the big
crash of the biggest Mexican party.
In one hand, they lost the presidency to the
conservatives.
On the
other, they lost the Major of the City of
Mexico to AMLO.
Becoming the major of the biggest metropoli
in all across South America is not a small
deal.
You get a
great showcase for your policies.
And this is why, 6 years alter, AMLO almost
won the presidency of the
country.
And what do you do when you “almost” win
an national election… and you are the new
left wing rockstar?
You accuse the Government of election fraud,
organize lots of demonstrations on the streets
and you let
your followers name you the “legitimate”
president.
And all of this could happen once again…
if he almost wins this time.
‘Clearly, this elections were unfair and
full of irregularities’
‘I said in democracy you can win and you
can loose.
But that was not a democracy’
But now that we know his history, let’s
have a look at his policies.
Basically, AMLO wants to undo all
the reforms made by the previous presidents.
Do you want examples?
Here we have the energy bill.
Prior to this law, all the Mexican oil was
managed by
the state owned company, PEMEX.
This company had big losts and all kinds of
corruption cases.
Peña Nieto
and his energy bill wanted to end this monopoly
so foreign companies could invest in the country.
As a
result, short term wise, gasoline prices went
sky high in some months.
This is why, AMLO wants to go back
to the previous situation, thinking that this
would solve the problem.
The same goes with the Education bill.
Prior to this one, teacher unions have a big
sway on the public
education.
Peña Nieto changed this.
The result was lots of protests organized
by those teachers unions.
And, again, AMLO wants to go backwards and
make those teachers happy.
And what about druck trafficking?
Well…
AMLO doesn’t stop in ending the war on drugs,
which could be kind
of reasonable… we wants to make an amnesty
on the big drug kingpings.
‘This so-called dangerous criminals are
mere babies compared to the corrupted politicians’
But the best of his policies are what we could
call the magic Tricks.
For example…
How do we end with
corruption?
Very easy!
You just nead to write a so-called ‘Moral
constitution’ and remove the legal
immunity that now enjoy the members of the
parliament.
This one is specially funny because this is
not the first time that we see a polician
connecting this two
principles: corruption and legal immunity.
And guess what?
The least corrupted countries in the planet:
Denmark and New Zealand HAVE legal immunity
to their member of the parliament.
Then again, it seems like
a very appealing policy for populists politicians
worldwide.
Anyway, AMLO seems to have easy and quick
solutions for everything.
Young unemployment?
Easy!
The
govermnent will employ thousands of youngsters.
And so on, so forth.
In other words…
AMLO and his brand new political party, the
so called, MORENA, generate a lot of sympathy
in half of the Mexican society… and a lot
of fea ron the other one.
And this is a problem because, if you wanna
run for office, scaring your enemies might
galvanize them on
the election day.
So the real question now is… to what extent
is AMLO willing to moderate his agenda?
POPULAR OR POPULIST?
Remember this name: ALFONSO ROMO.
He is a big businessman in MONTERREY and he
has been hired by AMLO to
become the campaign’s spokesperson.
What is his mission here?
Well… he is the man in charge of moderating
AMLO’s policies and make them more palatable
for the independent voters.
Having all the polls on his favour, AMLO needs
those votes badly.
And ALFONSO ROMO is the man for the
job.
He comes from the business world and he used
to support conservative candidates in the
past.
In
fact, many of AMLO’s advisors come from
different backgrounds, including the conservative
PAN party.
And
you can tell they are really softening AMLO’s
rethoric.
Do you remember I told you that AMLO wanted
to revoke the energy bill?
Well, now Alfonso Romo has said
that… ‘look guys, this was not so bad.
At the end of the day, we will just renegociate
the contracts with
foreign companies but they can stay in the
country, right?
We really looooove business.
Really!’
AMLO changed his mind and now he sais yes
to energy openness… according to Alfonso
Romo
But there is still a lot more last minute
moderation!
Look, AMLO is from a region called TABASCO.
And
there, there is a famous kind of fish called
PEJE *PRONOUNCED LIKE ‘PECHE’ IN CZECH*.
This is why, some
people nickname him as THE PEJE.
So now, in order to give the impression that
he will not nationalize
companies, nor rise taxes or expropriate properties
on a Venezuelan fashion, he has launched a
brand new
economic agenda called…
PEJENOMICS.
Isn’t it a catchy title?
But… as you know money is no big fan of
risks and experiments.
And, with or without flashy names and
mixed signals, the Mexican businessmen don’t
really trust AMLO.
This is why, while elections are getting
closer and closer, Mexican inteligentia has
already found their candidate.
Don’t forget that Mexico,
unlike other countries like France, has no
second round on the presidential elections.
This means that,
the one with the biggest share of voters on
July the 1st will become the president.
This is why, it seems
that the big antagonist to AMLO is going to
be this the conservative candidate, whose
name is RICARDO
ANAYA.
The Mexican business elite will support ANAYA
in order to stop LOPEZ OBRADOR
Being 39 years old, ANAYA is the youngest
candidate on this elections.
He is been accused of money
laundering.
But, despite what it looks, this hasn’t
hurt him during the campaign.
In fact, the opposite
is true.
People believe that this was just a dirty
deed from the PRI to disqualify him.
So he is gaining
momentum on the polls… although, he still
has a long way to surpass AMLO.
SO now the big question is…
Do you believe AMLO will become the next Mexican
president or maybe ANAYA
will challenge him?
Is AMLO a risk for Mexico or… it is hard
to do worse than the previous presidents?
Please, leave your answers on the comment
section below.
Also don’t forget to visit our friends from
RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM, the podcast that provided
the vocals in this episode that we not mine.
And, as
always, remember that we publish brand new
videos every week so hit that subscribe button
and you will
not miss any post.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and, as always, I see you next time.